Antingen så blir det en superhit eller så blir det en superflopp.
Det kan inte bli en flopp för det går redan så bra innan vi har rullat ut slutprodukten.
Så det är ingen risk i projektet längre, utan det kan bara bli en uppgradering.
För vi rullar inte ut med nytt, utan vi bara uppgraderar till vi spelar med fits.
Ringde mina kollegor, vi ska starta en podd nu.
Löste vi börja spela in på måndag.
Jag ska ringa Halftonbladet sen.
Jag ska hitta på ett namn för henne på podden.
Det behövs det verkligen en tur, inte du.
Det är den bästa idéen vi har.
Det kan bli bra.
Det kan bli hyggligt.
Det kör vi på.
Det får det bli.
Då går vi vidare.
Då säger vi välkommen till ännu ett avsnitt av Make Sweden Stronger där vi intervjuar träningsprofiler och hälsoprofiler från nutid och dåtid.
Men idag har vi med oss en gäst som har varit med över hela skalan.
Vi har med oss Ove Rytter.
Jajamensan, han är på plats.
Du har egentligen varit med sen styrketräningen lite tog fart i Sverige.
Om man vill säga.
Ja, verkligen.
När jag startade min första tid 1981 då fanns det fyra gym i Stockholm.
Nu finns det 728 tror jag något sånt där.
Det växer för varje dag.
Men då var det ju så att säga en ganska suspekt plats.
Dessutom var det bara män som tränade.
Det var ju inga kvinnor som tränade på de här gymmen när jag började.
Utan fanns inte ens omklädningsrum för kvinnor.
Så det har hänt väldigt mycket kan man väl säga de här åren.
Ja, och det låter ju som att det var väldigt, väldigt länge sedan men det är väl 45 år eller något sånt där.
Ja, precis så.
Man ska ju veta i perspektivet att om du tittar på de förebilder vi har, om man tittar på filosofer, konstnärer och sånt där, de kunde inte ens ta en varm dusch för hundra år sedan.
Så man ska vara glad varje dag man tar en varm dusch, för det är faktiskt en lyx vi har idag, eller man dricker rent vatten.
Så perspektivet går ju så fort idag, det är en logaritmisk utveckling och man glömmer ofta hur bra vi har den.
Ja, är det lite sjukt.
Men jag tänker att för dem som inte riktigt har koll på hela din resa, du har ju gjort rätt många nedslag i den här världen, men du var med och startade BODY, som hette något annat på den tiden, men eftersom alla unga känner det som body, så får det kallas för body.
Du var ju med och jag såg ju dig för första gången i gladiatorerna som kommentator, och sen så var du med och startade fitnessfestivalen och sen har du gjort tusen andra grejer.
Är det någonting där, vad är det folk brukar känna igen dig från mest?
Då får ju gammal man göra vilket kön man har.
Är man över 50 och tränar på gym, så vet de flesta män vilka jag äter som.
Mina böcker sålde ju väldigt mycket över hela Norden och USA också.
Så det var effektiv bodybuilding, skrev en bok då som vart ganska, inte banbrytande ska jag väl säga, men vad jag försökte göra var en lärobok i styrketränning vilket inte hade funnits riktigt tidigare.
Det var en kille som hette Henry Bergström som gjorde en bok en gång i tiden som hette Bygg dig stark.
Och den var ju ganska så, jag säger svart-vitt, ganska tunn, lite få övningar.
Då tänkte jag att jag skulle göra en bättre bok och då tog jag kontakt med, eftersom jag är journalist i grunden, så är det ju så att man kan inte vara expert på allt, man kan fråga experter.
Så jag anlittade de bästa som fanns i branschen och frågade om de tyckte om mina texter och ändrade lite och korrigerade fram och tillbaks.
Och gav ut en bok med 73 övningar och sedan kom det en till med 37 övningar, som hette Avancerad bodybuilding.
Och de böckerna håller vi faktiskt än idag om jag får säga det själv.
Det är inga klagomål.
Kommer ni in på någon brandstation i Sverige som sitter ofta på väggarna där det är en gammal gym så sitter bilderna på mina böcker.
Själva de har röjt ut sidorna och satt upp det som instruktioner.
Det gläder mig.
Är det en cred till boken eller är det synd att ingen har toppat det på 40 år?
Det är fortfarande the bible.
Det är ju så att det som på den tiden fanns inte internet.
Det fanns ingen som kunde googla sig till eller titta på YouTube.
Nu för tiden finns all information på nätet.
Det fanns ju inte då.
Tidningen var branschens Google med mitt pressbytt.
Jag hade mellan 12 och 17 sidor.
Det skulle aldrig vara djupgåva.
Men lika mycket text från resten av tidningen och massor med bilder.
Det var ju telefon och fax och ringa upp sina källor och samla ihop allt som hände under den månaden i tränningsbranschen.
Det var den enda informationskällan som fanns kan man väl säga.
Det var ett litet eget universum.
Kom du in i tränningsvärlden för att du kände att det här älskar jag, jag vill vara här eller har du bara runnit på?
Det där är en väldigt bra fråga därför att jag kan känna att beslutet är många olika händelser som kommer från olika håll.
Jag började på Handelshögskolan samt det som är landstaget i judo och det var en ohållbar kombi.
Vi hade träningsläger både i Sverige och utomlands nästan varenda helg.
Jag var tvungen att dra efter torsdag eftermiddag och ibland var det tenter på fredagar och missas.
Jag hoppade av efter en termin och klarade helt enkelt ett av det.
Sen så jobbade jag ett halvår och sökte journalisthögskolan, gick ut journalisthögskolan och under den här tiden jobbade jag extra på en butik som stålde styrketränningsskrivel bland annat.
Den heter Budo Fitness.
Där träffade jag Ingmar Dahl som var en skön kille.
Vi började spåna om tidningsidén eftersom jag skulle gå journalisthögskolan.
När jag gick ut journalisthögskolan så pitchade jag honom och startade en tidning.
Det var ganska naturligt för mig att starta en just om styrketränning, både bildning och vad man kallar det för, och kunde låga i linje med mina intressen och min kunskap och min förmåga att sammanställa andras kunskap.
Så vi drog igång tillsammans, han och jag.
Ingmar Dahl, startade du sedan träningsspecialisten med?
Som är en konkurrent till oss som fortfarande finns kvar och Budo Fitness finns också kvar.
Men har du nåt aktivt ägande fortfarande i träningsspecialisten?
Jag sålde 1989 och 1990, så jag har alltid, butiken var ju inte min idé kan man väl säga.
Ingmar, men fördelen med en butik av det slaget att man säljer saker till alla, vilket är fortfarande ganska neutralt.
Det var inte så att vi gick ut med, bastronerade ut vårt eget kostnedskortsmärke eller något sånt där.
Vi hade däremot våra gymkläder, så vi sålde och det var innan kan man säga klädindustrin kom igång på tränningssidan.
Så när jag sålde 89 eller 90 där och tog över tidningen 100 procent, så var det också mycket för att Ingmar ville skötta sin dit och jag skötte min dit.
Vi gjorde det vi var bra på på varsitt håll så att säga.
Det var all vänskap, vi separerade.
Då började jag satsa mer på tidningen, kan man säga, professionellt och utvecklingsmässigt.
Som du nämnde, vi har en bransch som har utvecklats lite logaritmiskt och det har ju gått från hela att styrketrädning blev mainstream till crossfit-grejen som kom för, vad kan det vara, nu fem, tio år sedan, till hela allting som sker med sociala medier och alla gyms som öppnade och allting däremellan.
Och du har ju varit med på ganska många av de stegen.
Kan du uppleva att du tycker att styrkevärlden rör sig åt rätt håll?
Eller tycker du att den har tagit lite felaktiga svingar på vägen?
Hade du önskat att det såg annorlunda ut i Sverige i dag än vad det gör?
Även det undrar.
Eller tycker du att det här är en bra utveckling?
Det är på rätt väg.
Jag tycker att det är en bra utveckling faktiskt.
Jag kan väl känna att det som händer när en sport eller en aktivitet utvecklas så kan det gå uppåt och det kan gå neråt och det kan bli ganska stabilt.
Jag menar det här är ju faktiskt ganska stabilt.
Om man tittar på de flugor som kommer upp, typ skateboard eller rollerblades eller det är en massa saker.
Gymmen är ju en samlingsplats för ett antal fysiska aktiviteter idag, vilket gör att man kan vara väldigt flexibel.
Det är en företagsidé som är ganska genial för att du kan forma dig efter de trender som kommer upp.
Du har ju lokalitet när du har dörrar och omklädningsrum, då marknadsvårdsapparaten, då dyker upp nya saker på marknaden så du bara integrerar.
Och eftersom det är så i Sverige att vädret är ju inte så bra året runt så är ju gymmet alltid en plats man kan gå till.
Så det har ju blivit en slags social inrättning för vuxna människor som vill fysiskt umgås med sig själv eller tillsammans med andra.
Och det tycker jag är fantastiskt.
Jag menar det var egentligen det som var visionen från början, att det ska vara integrerat och alla ska stötta varandra i ett sätt att leva ett hälsosammare liv.
Så svar på din fråga är ja, det tycker jag faktiskt att det har varit en bra utveckling.
Okej, vad kul.
Och vad tror du att vi tar vägen?
Vad tror du kommer hända med den här?
Kommer det gå åt hälsohållet eller kommer det dra iväg att 10% blir helt ortorrexiska och resten går ner, vad händer?
Utmaningen som hela branschen står inför, det är ju att om du tittar på den demografiska användarfliten av dem som verkligen går dit, det är åtta högutbildade människor som arbetar, som har ganska stor medvetenhet om hur viktigt det är att sköta sin fysik för att få ett bra liv.
Det är en klassfråga idag lite grann.
Det är egentligen dem som inte kommer till träningshallegnen så ska de gå hit mest såklart.
Då frågar man sig ängstligt, vad skulle man kunna göra för att de blir mer aktiva?
Det är där utmaningen ligger idag.
Jag tycker att kommuner, län och landsting idag ska ta ett större ansvar för pre-hab, det vill säga förebyggande hälsoarbete på olika sätt.
Jag kan ta ett exempel.
Om du tittar på en sport som kan ta skorst till exempel.
Skorst var oerhört populärt i början av 80-talet.
Det dök upp skorstarläggningar precis överallt.
Men man riktar in sig på män i 45-årsåldern med kulmagen som började komma i form och där låg man i hela sin marknadsföringsbudget.
Men man glömde bort de nya som kom.
Det fanns ingen aktivitet att stimulera tillväxt vilket gjorde att de dog ut de här ställena såklart.
Dessutom är det en väldigt skadedrabbad del av idrottsvärlden vilket gjorde att många skadade sig, sprang in i väggen, brutna näser, hälsa när den gick och så vidare.
För bubbarna var inte i form på att göra det där.
Gymmen, idag tycker jag att man ska sänka åldern att få komma in och börja träna med föräldrar väldigt lågt, för det är egentligen där man fostrar.
Det skulle kunna finnas om man har de flesta, gymvärdet ser så annorlunda ut idag.
Det drivs av 57 stora drakar som driver hela gymbranschen.
Full respekt för de gör ett fantastiskt arbete, tycker många och dessutom gör det väldigt bra.
De har lite olika approach, lite olika prisbild, lite olika segment.
Men det stora hela tycker jag är fantastiskt att ha möjligheten att kunna träna på massa anläggningar för ett enda kort och så vidare.
Men jag kan sakna ungdomsverksamheten, där man har fritt valt arbete i skolan hade vi när jag var ung, man kunde välja någon typ av aktivitet.
Man skulle kunna ha på lågtryckvänta tider att ungdomar fick komma och prova med en PT för att skapa morgondagens målgrupp.
För det är där den logaritmiska utvecklingen sker.
Därför idag är det så att de är så extremt digitala idag ungdomar.
Det är ingen som kollar på liniärtv, de lever i mobiltelefonen.
Man ska göra snygga inramningar i roliga klasser man kan träna eller roliga passer man kan träna.
Så man kan filma, dela med kompisar och få en digital delningsutveckling.
Där tror jag att man har stor potential för att öka tillväxten på medlemssidan.
Varför är det ingen som gör det?
Det är ingen som har med mig i styrelsen.
Hahahaha Det slår mig ibland hur man missar den här.
Jag är själv en pappa i sen ålder så att säga och då blir det så att jag ser utvecklingen.
Kommer det inga reklam till ungdomar, det kommer bara godis och dataspel och kommer det ingen reklam för att vara sundare?
Ja, men så är det ju.
Det är ju över taget så att hela den kommersiella branschen som lurar mänskligheten idag, det är ju så att det finns inget TB, det vill säga vinstmarginal på nyttiga produkter många gånger.
Det är bara verktyg, skumbilar, socker, läsk, det är liksom chips och det är dipp och allt vad det är som marknadsförs reklammässigt.
Vad ska ungdomarna tro?
Ja, men det är klart att reklam påverkar till det man köper, men det är väldigt sällan man ser en nyttig produkt.
Just matsidan är ju en lucka idag i hela träningsbranschen, därför att utan en korrekt kost så blir det inga resultat.
Det vet ju alla som har tränat länge, men jag är äldre nu och det jag kan se på min egen kropp bara på en månad om jag missköter kosten.
Och det är ju så här att missköter du kosten år efter år utan att ens veta om det så är det ödesigert.
Så att den kommersiella livsmedelsindustrin är den största boven idag för att människor inte mår bra.
Och då blir steget ännu större att komma in och ställa sig träningskläder på djur.
Verkligen, jag fastnar lite i affärsidéer här samtidigt som du pratar.
Det finns ju några luppor både i att börja jobba med unga.
Jag vet ju själv, jag har ju två unga pojkar och jag ser ju på andra föräldrar i våran bekantskap.
De har ju svårt att aktivera sina barn.
Eller ofta blir det ju att deras barn ska ha en idrott i veckan och då kanske de har ett pass.
Och jag funderar ju på när jag själv var liten, då gick man ju på allt som gick.
För att det var ju det man blev ivägskickad på.
Och det var det som fanns.
Så att man hade ju inte så mycket annat.
Och då är inte jag så gammal än.
Så att det liksom, det har ju hänt väldigt mycket där.
Men att kunna ta med barnen till gymmet på det sättet hade ju varit ett jäkligt skönt sätt att få in dem varje dag.
Så fan om någon lyssnar på det får de ta den, affärsidéen.
Ja, men alltså när du pratar om luckor, så tycker jag att man tänker lite fel.
Därför det finns inga luckor egentligen.
Utan vad det handlar om det är att, vad ska jag ta som exempel, ta bilindustrin till exempel.
Hur många bilmodeller finns det?
Ska jag starta ett bilmärke men det finns inga lucka där.
Det är ju så mycket bilar.
Men gör du någonting som är bäst, så blir det ju en ny lucka.
Du kan inte säga hur stor en bransch är förrän du gör en optimal produkt.
Jag menar vad är en lucka?
Ja, när jag gav ut min första tidning så fanns det redan en tidning.
Det fanns inga lucka där och det var bara fyra gym.
Men jag skapade en produkt som förhoppningsvis var mycket bättre.
Mer genomarbetad, mer färg, specialister, frågespalter, skvaller.
Jag gjorde en produkt, jag tror jag mig själv som exempel, det kanske är en låt dig gå centris, men det fanns ju en lucka.
Det är ju du som är gäst den här.
Ja tack, men då är det ju så att jag hittade inte en lucka, jag hittade en uppgradering av redan existerande verksamhet.
Det är inte samma sak som en lucka.
Så om man ska tänka, vad är det som finns idag?
Vad kan jag göra bättre?
Det är inte en lucka, det kan uppgradera någonting som är bra.
Jag vet inte vad du håller på med, du säljer ju utrustning eller hur?
Träningsutrustning.
Och jag menar, finns det någon lucka där?
Herregud, hur många finns det förut?
Det finns säkert hundra tillverkade träningsrättskapelser i världen.
Jag ser ingen lucka där.
Men jag ser däremot en uppgradering av vissa segment inom den nischen.
Jag har massor med idéer på produkter jag tycker fattas på den, just den nischen, som jag skulle vilja göra.
Jag kan tipsa er på några sen som tror jag är fantastiska.
Det är också ofta nischade produkter som bygger trovärdigheten för hela varumärket.
Är det så du har gått in i business när du har startat olika projekt eller företag att du har känt att här behövs en uppgradering eller har det varit mer en lustfylld?
Båda delarna, men en annan sak är att jag ser varje bransch som en tårta.
Vilken tårtbit kan du bli bäst i?
När du blir bäst i en tårtbit, då kan du börja bygga en tårtbit till och en tårtbit till.
Så att börjar man på ett ställe ska man bygga, som i mitt fall byggde i förstidningen, event, böcker, resor, butik, gym.
Alltså vi skapade liksom en liten värld kring vår tårtbit som vi lyckade i början.
Jag brukar alltid säga att man måste börja bygga en väg och se vart den leder.
Och det vågar man inte satsa på en enda tårtbit, då ska man byta tårta helt.
Men i den tårtan måste du finna en jäkla glädje i den tårtbiten.
Du ska känna att det här är min jävla tårtbit, kom inte hit och nagga på den här, då får den jobba.
Och det är så man måste tänka.
Man ska inte ta hela tårtan på en gång, för gör man någonting som heter allt för alla, då misslyckas man såklart.
Då måste du hitta din egen nisch.
Det gäller träning, det gäller redskap, det gäller bilar, det gäller precis vad som helst.
Så det här med lucka handlar om uppgradering och tårtbit.
När du pratar om det så känns det ganska genomtänkt, eller det känns som att du har haft den tanken med dig ganska länge.
Har du haft något företag här där du har stagnerat och känt att det här inte är roligt, men du har målt på i alla fall?
Vad var det som gjorde att du fastnade då?
Jag var så irriterad på att det inte fanns någon bra restaurang att gå och käka lunch på.
Det var bara dagens rätt med massa fett och såsar och dykt, eller dykt men det var bara gräpa.
Därför ska du få marginaler på en lunch.
Luncher som du vet är ganska billigt.
Det är fortfarande ganska...
Då startade jag tillsammans med min bror Björn Lindgren och Henke Rymar och en kille till startade vi restaurang Kalori.
Bara nyttig mat var den första nyckelhålsmarknadsrestaurangen i Sverige.
Den startade jag för att någonstans gå och äta själv.
Det var fantastiskt att ha den, vi hade den sex-sju år.
Problemet är bara att när du kommer in i ett segment som är så förstört, det vill säga utav kommersiella produkter som billiga råvaror, som korv, pizza, dagens köttbit som är nåt riktigt skräp.
Vi försökte servera högkvalitativ mat från assortimentet från en leverantör, med fisk, kyckling, kalkon, filé och så vidare.
Skysta grönsaker, allting var ekologiskt, ekologiskt kaffe, allting var perfekt, så man kunde äta precis lika bra som hemma.
Problemet är att bra mat är svårt att tjäna pengar på, om att det tar orimligt betalt, och det kan du inte göra på en lunch.
Så vi drev ju det där med skräpblandad förtjusning, trots att vi hade knöt fullt så vart det ingenting över.
Det beror på att vi är fostrade, på den tiden kostade dagens lunch 60 kronor typ.
Då fick du lite pasta och en grädd sås och lite fet bacon i.
Det äter ju folk att betala för, men TB på det är 50 kronor, det kostar ingenting att göra.
Men om du däremot serverar kycklingfilé med schyssta grölsaker, quinoa eller bakpotatis eller vad vi nu hade så blir du en helt annan prisbild.
Vi hade nästan 48 procent i kostnader för maten vi serverade.
Sen har du en personal och så kör man allting vitt.
Vilket inte alla gör eller så man försöker köra business på schysst sätt, betala sin skatt och hålla alla regelverk.
Och ska man göra det i restaurangbranschen så förstår jag de som jobbar i en så jobbar svart för det är nästan omöjligt att få det att gå runt.
Speciellt om de inte serverar alkohol vilket vi inte gjorde.
Vi körde ju bara naturprodukter, kombucha, ljuser och färskpessat.
De som uppskattade uppskattade enormt.
Vi hade tagit en liten tårtbit, för den där tårtbiten var för dyr att driva.
Jag sålde det där till Henke som var en som var, som jag säger, the main man i det där.
Underbar människa som jag fortfarande älskar.
Han drev det vidare själv och då var det lite mer på familjenivå.
Tog in lite döttrar och jobbade kanske på ett annat sätt.
Han fick väl där att snurra men det var inte mycket mer än så.
Det var liksom ingen stjärnkrog som man kunde försörja sig på i flera familjer, utan det var mycket jobb och det var mest bekymmelser.
Det är egentligen så svårt på din fråga är att det är egentligen det enda projekt jag har drivit.
Jag har känt att jag var kvar lite för länge och lärde mig lite mycket tid och pengar.
Men det var från hjärtat.
Jag förstår, det var ett äkta passionsprojekt.
Ja det var det verkligen.
Tror du att det kommer komma en lucka för den sortens företag?
Många har försökt att driva det här.
Vi gjorde, vi gick ju med i Svenska Franchise-förbundet och man kunde ansöka om Franchise på Restaurant Calorie, som det hette då.
Och vi hade massor av ansökningar.
Alltså det bara drällde in ansökan på att vi skulle starta, vi kolla på lokaler och allting.
Men jag hade inte hjärtat att driva det vidare, för moden, det vill säga grundrestaurangen, gjorde ingen vinst direkt.
Då kände jag såhär, stackarna som tar rörelse, de får samma slit som oss, de kommer att tjäna några pengar.
Så jag hade en del annat att göra också, så jag släppte det där allt mer, så jag köpte Henke ut mig.
Det var en underbar historia, och det är lärorikt men vi kan tjäna pengar på det.
Man kan driva saker och till och med betala lite varje år för att driva något som man brinner för, men man får sju år och förlorar lite varje år, det är inget ordet längre.
Så jag kom ut med skräckland och förtjusning, och det var egentligen det enda bolag jag drivit har känt att...
Jag ångrar absolut inte, men det har varit ingen hit.
Jag fattar.
Du har ju ett antal personer här som redan, nu när du bara har nämnt några bolag, återkommer om och om igen.
Vi har ju Ingmar Dahl där som verkar ha varit med på ett antal, och så din bror, det är en matsrytta va?
Vad är det du söker i dina partners?
Vad är det för drag eller vad är det för kompetenser?
För det första kan man inte välja sin egen bror.
Han har jag inte valt, utan han och jag har jobbat ihop.
Vi jobbade från 1981 när vi startade, han var min första anonsäljare.
Vi jobbade ihop fram till mitten på...
Det beror på hur man menar med att jobba ihop.
Jag startade i Fitnessmagasin 1994 där med Jonas Bonnier och gännen på Fancy Media.
Sen drev vi det fram till medrenningsskiftet och köpte ut Bonnier från det och det blev brorsan vd för det bolaget.
Hur länge var jag med sen?
Jag kommer inte ihåg.
2007 sålde jag B&K.
Kanske 2011 sålde jag det sista i Fitnessmagasin och var brorsan kvar där.
Men min bror är fantastisk.
För första är det något man kan lita på till 100 procent, det är viktigt.
Han är...
Jag och min bror är väldigt olika men snabbt lite lika.
Han är snällare än vad jag är.
Han är mjukare och jag kan aldrig glömma en story när vi skulle börja jobba ihop och jag och Mats.
Då satt vi var så seriöst på skrivbordet och började ringa i telefoner.
Det är alltid spännande när man startar ett nytt bolag när man börjar ringa.
Första samtalet glömmer jag aldrig.
Och då ringde någon som ville annonsera och jag hör hans dialog med den här annonsören och så säger annonsören Ja men ska du verkligen ha en helsida?
Ska du inte börja med en halvsida?
Vad fan håller du på med?
Han ska köra en helsida.
Men han byggde förtroende på det sättet.
Han tyckte att han skulle prova en halvsida och se vad han tyckte på respons.
Och på det sättet, och just den annonsören var vår mest trogna annonsör sedan genom åren.
Det var faktiskt gymgryssistan.
Så det har varit mycket vatten som har flutat under broren av min bror.
Vi har drivit många bolag ihop.
Och vi är fortfarande delägare gemensamt i ett projekt.
Ingmar var väl egentligen en nyckelperson för att det hela skulle lyfta.
Han drev postorderverksamhet inom styrketrädare, han hade CITO-tränningssällskap bland annat.
Och så de hade ju ett postorderegister där vi kunde mejla ut vår första, eller mejla ut på den tiden, vi postade ut mellan 6 och 9 tusen av dessa som hade köpt någonting någon gång från det här företaget.
Och då var man intresserad av styrketrädare så vi fick ju nästan tusen prenumeranter på det utskicket.
Där är det mer än 98 kronor kostade för helårsprogrammation.
Fick vi 98 000 det täckte väl i princip första trycket och så vidare.
Men en lön tog jag inte ut första åren, jag jobbade parallellt med andra saker för att kunna leva.
Och sen så vart efter det gick lite bättre så kunde man börja ta ut lite lön.
Men skulle du säga att...
Så Ingmar är liksom...
Ingmar är ju så askönt, men Ingmar är så otroligt...
Han är alltså så otroligt i framkant, det ska han ja.
Han var duktig, han kunde layouta lite, han var intresserad av teknik, vi köpte in mycket tekniska grejer som jag inte var bekant med då.
Han tog tag i frågan om programationshanteringssystem.
Han jobbar mycket med kan man säga de infrastrukturellt riktiga sakerna för ett bolaget skulle växa, medan jag skapade innehållet.
Då man säger att han var hjärnan som jag har hjärtat som man brukar säga ibland, att jag försökte brinna för det som vi skulle förmedla, och han såg till att det praktiska med banker och allt sånt där funkade.
För att när vi skulle starta så behövde vi en miljon i lån, det var mycket på den tiden.
Det gick vi upp till Sparbanken Kronan.
Vi var på flera banker men vi gick upp till Sparbanken Kronan som det hette då, nuvarande Swedbank.
Presentera idén och de gav oss en miljon i lån.
Utan större säkerhet och därför är man trogen kundare än idag såklart.
En liten tjata till dem.
Om jag skulle sammanfatta er då så skulle, det jag hör är att man ska lita på personen och de ska get shit bland.
Det är de viktiga kvaliteterna.
Ärliga, innovativa och så ska man kunna skratta ihop.
Ingmar och jag har skrattat så fruktansvärt mycket.
Men man ska också kunna prestera.
Man får inte vara rädd för att jobba.
Vi kunde sitta tills sent på nätterna tillsammans.
Han hade familj och barn och det var inte alltid så populärt.
Men man är tvungen att jobba dubbelt så hårt för halva lönen i början om man ska lyckas med någonting.
Man kan inte tro att det bara går in i en öppen värld och så funkar allting.
Utan man måste ha smör och bröd på bordet.
I mitt fall var det tropisk och ris.
Sedan kör man tills det blir några intäkter.
Men man får inte vara för beroende av det man startat så att livet står och faller med det.
För då är man på halis.
Har du haft några sådana perioder i ditt liv när det har varit riktigt tajt eller illa ut det?
Eller har det gått hyggligt sen start inom den här världen?
Förutom första åren givetvis som allt det är astunget.
Så det gick ju, man kan väl säga så här, det var ett paradigmskifte lönsamhetsmässigt 90.
Jag tog över tidningen då och i samma veva så gick Fredab, pressens distributionstjänst i Eskilstuna AB, i konkurs.
Det är ungefär som posten går i konkurs.
Vi hade hela vår upplaga tryckt, stod på kajen nere i Eskilstuna och den kom inte ut.
Eftersom jag hade upplagit både i Sverige och Norge, senare Finland också men, så var det en ganska prekär situation.
Och då gjorde jag en grej som jag fortfarande än idag inte förstår jag kom på, utan jag köpte en tidning som inte var utedöpta om den till B&K Sportsmagazin, sluta över den på en annan distributionskanal som hade sagt nej till alla.
Men eftersom jag kunde byta namn på den existerande tidningen i, vilket gick till på ett väldigt speciellt sätt.
Men så gick det till så att jag var inne, sen fick jag en större distributionskanal och vi var tvungna att spara.
Vi hade ju 5-8 miljoner i fordringar, vilket var extremt mycket pengar då.
Vad jag fick göra var att vi drog ner allting.
Jag gjorde retronummer, minst från förr.
Det var bara gamla bilder, gamla reportage.
Vi gjorde vad vi kunde.
Vi smaktade ihop den här tidningen så att det skulle komma ut i tid.
Köpte inte in någonting, jag bytte namn.
Jag hittade fiktiva namn, skrev mer än någonsin.
Alla jobbade hårdare, alla fick vänta med lön.
Men alla gick med på det på redaktionen, många på den tiden.
Och sen efter när det började komma intäkter igen, var det inte kalla lön, var det efter pengarna kom in.
Och sen efter sju månader så kommer ett brev från myndigheten, där det stod att akordet är klart, ni får tillbaka 82,5 procent.
Vilket gjorde att besparingen hade gjort var enorm, medan intäkterna var inte riktigt lika mycket som de hade förhoppningsvis.
Då hade vi lite bättre än någonsin efter det.
Och då hade jag ju tagit över tidningen så att vi köpte och skaffade en nytt kontor, uppgraderade vår maskinpark och körde ännu hårdare.
Men då var det en kris.
När det hände en konkurs var man helt knäckt.
Det var inte roligt.
Då var man svämdlös i tre veckor.
Då följde allting.
Det var som ett korthus.
Det var tufft men det grejade sig.
Det är lite svårt att förstå att en distribution kan dö ut eller bara inte tillåtas.
Styrelsen i bolaget i fråga fick inte ansvarsfrihet.
De hade räknat lite fel.
De skulle ha lagt på några ören till, var det returrex eller vad det var.
Det gjorde det att de var tvungna att sätta det i KK.
Vad de inte tänkte på var att det var 300 tidningar som satt i KK samtidigt.
Det var en fruktansvärldsituation.
Vi skapade en krisgrupp och jag var med i den krisgruppen.
Det som jag blev så förvånad över när jag var med, jag trodde att vi var en liten, ursäkta uttrycket, skittidning på marknaden.
Men det var vi inte, vi var en av de absolut största.
Alla ljuger om sina upplager.
Vi hade verkligen en stor upplaga och en udda produkt, vilket alla varit så förvånade över.
Vi hade fått fästet på marknaden, vi sålde väldigt bra.
Folk än idag har ju sparat gamla numrar, i alla årgångar och allting.
Det är ju en collectorsmagazin idag.
Om vi kan snacka om tablemagazin, en dagstidning sparar man inte.
Men en sån här produkt är ganska kul att titta tillbaks till.
Det är många som har sparat det här i lådvis.
Det är ju också tydligt på att det fyllde ett behov på den tiden, så det var ganska stort.
Du har ju en väldigt lång bakgrund inom vad kallar man då, journalistik eller skrivande eller content eller vad man nu vill.
Jag vet inte vad du kallar dig själv.
Redaktör kanske.
Men hur ser du på hela AI-framväxten och att information inte direkt har någon ägare utan att man bara kan producera material utan upphovsrätt?
Det är en ganska stor etisk problematik där.
Eller man dödar ju kanske grundarbetet.
Ja, så trodde man när musiken släpptes fri också.
Det är så här att vi behöver inte gå och köpa vinylskiv.
AI är fantastiskt.
Du ska tänka så här att AI är ju en assistent.
Det är ingen arbetskraft.
Det är en assistent i arbetskraften som kommer spara skattepengar.
Det kommer spara meningslösa uppgifter.
Det kommer spara enormt mycket liv.
Om jag ska ta AI som en liten sidospår här, så jobbar jag ganska mycket med digitala produkter idag, det är en av mina huvudstilsutsättningar.
Så är det så här att vitala delar av AI är väldigt viktigt för framtida utveckling.
Vi har kommit så långt nu att det är tid att det kommer in för att vi slipper mycket meningsfullt arbete och för att kunna sätta fingret på vad AI egentligen har för betydelse så kan jag ta några exempel som man kanske inte tänker på.
Hur kan ett företag integrera AI så att det sparar skattepengar, ta det som exempel då.
Om du tar domstolsverket i Sverige så får de 3800 domstol ut varje år från utlandet så de är ju pernvis tjocka.
Idag kan AI läsa in dem och översätta dem på tre minuter till det var tre veckors arbete på skattepetalarnas bekostnad.
Där spar vi mycket skattepengar.
En jurist måste ändå titta på det efteråt eftersom det gjorde man även om du översätts utan en icke kvalificerad jurist.
De kostar ännu mer att sitta och översätta så där har vi en liten detalj.
Om du tar SJs till exempel.
SJ har idag integrerat AI i kamerabevakning utan obevakade övergångar.
De ser om ett djur eller en bil eller en människa rör sig i närheten vilket gör att det kan snabbt identifiera till tågföraren som kommer åkande, som kan sakta ner och spara liv.
AI har väldigt många fina saker, då kan man tänka såhär, när det kommer till upphov som man har rätt.
Då är vi inne på en väldigt stor fråga.
Det är så här idag, har du kommit på redskapsmarknaden?
Är det du som har uppfunnit färdningsmaskinen?
Jag vill ju tro det men...
Nej det är det inte.
Det var Gustav Sanders i 1800-talet.
Han fick ingen upphovsrätt på färdningsmaskiner.
Alla kopierar honom idag.
Det är ingenting idag som vi försörjer oss på som är unikt.
En konstnär som ritar en tavla har tagit in från massa olika människor, sätter ihop i sitt eget huvud till ett eget konstverk.
Jag jobbar exakt lite grann.
Det är en extern hjärna som samlar extremt mycket information av sådant som redan finns.
Så om du sitter och funderar tillräckligt länge på en sak så kan du göra samma sak men det tar liksom 100 år kanske.
Så att den logaritmiska utvecklingen på AI är fantastisk samtidigt som det är lite skrämmande kan man tycka.
Men jag tror att det kommer bli så här att de som kan AI kommer att ha enormt hjälp av det.
De som inte accepterar det och mottarbetar det kommer att bli självt av det.
Man måste våga integrera det nya hela tiden annars är man en bakåtsträvare.
Sedan kommer den personliga servicen aldrig kunna ersätta AI.
Det man trodde för var när robotiseringen till exempel integrerades i Sverige.
Nu kommer robotarna, det kommer inte finnas några hantverkare kvar eller om man har hantverkare och kraft att få ta tag i en hantverkare därför att du kan aldrig robotisera mänskligt finarbete.
Du kan däremot robotisera tråkiga arbetsutrymter som sparar kroppen, det som sliter på kroppen och sparar kroppen.
Robotiseringen var fantastisk, grund och tal till exempel bryggerinäringen där folk skulle gå och lasta flaskor från sju på morgon till fem på kvällen med en kort paus i mitten innan arbetstiden förkortades.
Men de slet ut ryggen och dog i ett förtid och fick ett fruktansvärt skadedrabbat liv.
Idag när du ser ett bryggeri ser du inte en människa, du ser någon som sitter och sköter robotarna, därför får jobba med andra saker.
De jobbade sedan för att utveckla AI.
De jobbade med att utveckla robotisering.
Så att vi är inne i en period som är oerhört viktig att ta till sig att man måste följa med och förstå värdet istället för att bara se hotet.
Jag tog musiken som exempel när streamingen kom och alla motarbetar motarbetar motarbetar.
Plötsligt inser man, vänta lite här nu, det finns något som kallas för the long tail.
Plötsligt kan man lyssna på Kalle Jula, bor från Finland på början av 1900-talet, hans låtar.
Plötsligt får hans familj lite intäkter på det.
Allt har goda saker med sig och onda saker med sig, men jag tror att i faset på det är det mer gott än ont.
Du pratade att du jobbar lite med det digitala idag.
Jag har egentligen två frågor i denna, men båda två är stora frågor.
Kan du berätta lite om vad du jobbar med idag, eller vilka projekt du är inne i idag?
Sen är jag lite nyfiken på, det är relativt ovanligt att någon är inne i en bransch så pass länge, men hela tiden väljer att förnya sig eller hänga med i nya trender som kommer.
Kanske inte nya trender utan snarare nya paradigmskiften som kommer.
För AI är ju inte en trend eller digitaliseringen inte en trend, utan det är ju någonting som stöper om en elmarknad.
Är det ett drag du har eller har du tvingats ha det eller tycker du bara att det är intressant?
Så dels, vad sysslar du med nu och dels hur har du gjort för att hänga med och ligga i framkant på marknaden?
Jag kan börja med att svara på den senaste frågan, om den enda svaret jag har är nyfikenhet.
En oerhört nyfiken människa.
Jag går på mellan en och fyra föreläsningar i veckan.
Inom olika saker, finans, hälsa, digitalisering, AI, foodtech, healthtech, medtech.
Jag tycker det är spännande.
Därför att om man förstår så blir man inte lika negativ.
Så fort du inte förstår någonting, det är för att folk ser att jag är bodybilder.
Herregud, man är ju supersuspekt.
Men om man förklarar för människor varför jag styrka tränar, att man bygger upp sitt mänskliga batteri för att bli en starkare individ och man gör det på ett schysst sätt i hela sitt liv, då förstår folk och det är först på äldre dag, jag borde också ha tränat lite.
Acceptansen kommer bara med att man kan någonting och det området som man håller på med.
Så att nyfikenheten är det som driver mig framåt, måste jag väl säga.
Och när det kommer till vad jag gör, då är det så att det tar alldeles för lång tid att berätta om allting.
Men jag investerar i bolag och jag tycker förändrar världen på ett positivt sätt.
Och det är allt ifrån finansiering av skolor, barn och daghem och hälsoanläggningar.
Det är syrgas, det är säkerhet för att motverka för hemska bomdåd och smuggling av knark.
Jag har satsat lite på en app som hjälper gravid kvinnor före, under och efter graviditet.
Och det stora projektet jag håller på med är ett projekt inom digital media där vi bygger ett förlagshus med digitala tidningar med självgenererande konten från samtliga digitala plattformar inom just ditt område.
Så vi driver idag faktiskt ett projekt som enligt flyger under radan, som vi kommer att release här inom kort.
Eller rättare sagt det funkar jättebra redan nu.
Vi har hållit på i fem, sex år och det är lönsamt från början.
Det går väldigt bra.
Jag vågar inte ens säga, jag ska inte nämna några siffror, därför ni tror att jag sitter och yrar.
Men det är en väldigt väldigt stor produkt och vi är ett gäng, ett ganska stort gäng som jobbar med det här.
Jag är inte operativ, jag är bara med i investeringsgruppen som ser till att vi kan kapitalisera vartefter.
Bolaget i sig går väldigt bra, det behöver inga pengar för att driva bolaget, det ger goda vinster, men vi bakar in det att utveckla motorn ytterligare.
Nu jobbar vi direkt med Microsoft FastTrack Team i hela världen där vi interagerar med dem och hjälper oss att integrera just de delar av AI vi har med i produkten.
När vi har slut pratat klart kan jag dela en länk med dig, så du får se min lilla värld jag har.
Jag har byggt upp något som heter Fitness Space.
I dag har vi i vår motor så har vi totalt 50 miljoner besök, varav 20% inne varje månad.
Vi bygger upp hela projektet på traditionell annonsförsäljning, precis som Facebook, Instagram och TikTok.
Det är helt gratis.
Det är en produkt som kommer att förändra.
Man kan väl säga att det är ett Netflix för hela Internetoceanen, där du kan välja innehåll från det du är intresserad av.
Du kan även bygga din egen sociala plattform, precis som på Facebook, fast du får integrera flöden per automatik från de källor du vill ha.
Hur hittar vi dem då?
Jo, man gör så kallade content-
arkitekturer.
Det tar lite för lång tid att börja prata html, programmering och sådant.
Hur man hittar dem här.
Men det stora hela går ut på att vi har hittat ett sätt att göra det här ihop med Microsoft.
De har tagit oss som ett exempel på hur man kan utveckla deras Asia-plattform bland annat.
Och hur man kan optimera deras tjänster på ett fantastiskt sätt.
Det är ett fantastiskt bolag att jobba med.
Därför har du expertis.
Så det är det jag jobbar med mest.
Så vad jag gör är att jag presenterar projektet för investorer.
Och så får de vara med eller inte.
Idag har vi 211 delägare.
Vi är 11 som är huvudbolaget och resten satsar lite mindre pengar.
Och vi har byggt upp det här under alla år.
Tagit in ungefär 300 miljoner.
Nu tar vi in lite till för att rulla ut det via Social Chain i hela världen på 36 språk och på tre kontinenter.
Så det är ett stort projekt.
Men det är oerhört, man blir entreprenör i en helt ny nisch på äldre dagar men samtidigt så känner jag att det ligger helt i limmen som jag gjort tidigare.
Det är skillnaden på att det är ett förlag som är digitalt istället för fysiskt print.
Och mycket snabbare, mycket mindre kostnader, mycket framförallt...
Vad man kan tycka då som journalist är att vad finns den kritiska granskningen?
Det fina med det här är att det gör AI-motorn.
Därför att om du är en profil som har extremt mycket följare, extremt mycket delningar, extremt mycket rörligt material, så är du en källa som alla folk lyssnar på.
Så att vår motor väljer ut de mellan 2-4 procentens största profilerna inom varje nisch.
Det kan vara så att nischat som just i mitt mån så är det allt från personal training till nutrition, arm wrestling, powerlifting, fitness, bodybuilding, vad det är.
Så just i mitt mån, som då är 11 olika tidningar, kan man säga, eller sociala mediatlattformar, så får du realtid varje dag, information från de största källorna inom varje segment.
Och nu när vi har sett att säga, förfina produkten vid utrullningen, den funkar bra redan nu, men då blir ytterligare TikTok integrerats, och vi integrerar även en snabbare uppdatering.
Beroende på hur mycket trafik varje tidning drar, eller varje plattform drar, så uppdateras den varannan timme.
Och ibland kanske varje dygn, ibland kanske var ett tredje dag.
Det beror lite på hur mycket trafik, det är mycket som händer just i segmentet.
Det händer inte lika mycket i alla.
Det är allt från drone flying till tv-serier till politik, geografi, vi har liksom allt.
Det är 3.012 tidningar idag.
Det är det vi kommer att öka på hela tiden.
Sedan är produkten släppsfri.
Om man kan göra sin egen så finns det 100.000 områden.
Någon kanske vill skriva om rosa pudlar, någon vill ha handikappade skepprar, vet jag, eller katter.
Eller det finns hästar, det finns så mycket områden i dag.
Det finns glasögon, det finns mode, det kan inte vi sitta och skapa.
För om man tittar på de stora plattformarna, varför är Facebook, TikTok och Instagram så stort?
Det beror inte på att de som sitter i USA sitter och gör tiderna.
Det är vi som producerar innehållet och bygger värde.
Det är en plattform vi levererar, inte ett förlag.
Men förlaget måste finnas i botten för att ha någonting att titta på.
Du kan inte starta en sportbutik med fyra skor i.
Du måste ha 100, 200, 300 olika märken, eller sorter, eller modeller för att det ska vara intressant att gå in.
Det är så man drar igång en digital plattform av större format, som är mer avancerad.
När sker utrudningen?
När får man reda på namnet på den här satsningen?
Jag kan säga vad den heter, den kommer att heta Social XP, och den heter det redan nu, fast idag leds trafiken in via delningar.
Den stora motorn i hela digitala oceanen är ju delningar.
Det är ju så man får trafik.
Jag menar du ser aldrig reklam på Facebook eller Instagram eller TikTok.
De skickar till dig att gå in och ladda ner vår app.
Det är ju så att dina kompisar delar ju till dig vad de tycker är kul.
Det kommer lite klipp från Youtube, det kommer något från TikTok, det kommer något från Instagram.
Då klickar du på det och så plötsligt har de fått mer trafik.
Delningar är ju hela tillväxten.
Det är ju en väldigt billigt sätt att marknadsföra på.
Så vi har inkastare i formen av Instagramkonton och därefter så är det delningar som gäller.
Okej, det ska bli spännande att hålla ögonen öppna om det blir mainstream nära.
Ja, om du fattar så är det en av de få som gör det.
Du får inte ta en stund och klippa det här för att det är någonting helt nytt.
Men vi får se.
Det är ju som jag brukar säga att det här med att man ska bygga en väg för att se var det leder, det är ju här exakt sådant projekt va.
Antingen så blir det en superhit eller så blir det en superflopp.
Men som det känns just nu så är det ingen, det kan inte bli en flopp för det går redan så bra innan vi har så att säga rullat ut slutprodukten.
Så det är ingen risk i projektet längre utan det kan bara bli en uppgradering.
Så vi rullar inte ut något nytt utan vi bara uppgraderar något som redan finns.
Var ni ett litet gäng från början eller kom du in lite senare eller var detta tanken, vi behöver inte fastna så mycket i detta men jag ser ju att du tycker att detta är kul liksom.
Ja det är skitkul.
Jag kan säga helt ärligt hur det gick till.
En god vän till mig som oerhört framgångsrik digital ringde mig om det här projektet och då var in i en period i livet jag inte var så sugen på att satsa på något nytt eftersom min fru var väldigt sjuk och jag kände att när hon klarade den, hon hade ju kanser visst att den inte skulle klara det, då kände jag att jag kommer inte orka att starta någonting nytt.
Så jag tackade nej två gånger.
Det slutade innan så här, nu får du tänka en gång till.
Kolla här så satt jag mig in lite mer och det kände att det var ganska skönt.
Så jag satte mig ner och gjorde så kallade contentarchitektur.
För mig var det lite mental bortkoppling från vardagen.
Jag satt tre till fem veckor dagligdags och tog det som ett jobb.
Det var jävligt intressant att se hur man kan detektera de största profilerna i världen på olika områden.
Och sen baka ner det med länkar så att motorn kunde hitta dem och därigenom hitta deras följare och se hur mycket följare de hade och hur mycket inlägg de hade.
Plötsligt den här tårtbiten som jag pratade om tidigare, här hade vi verkligen en tårtbit på någonting som redan är så jävla superetablerad.
Den här tårtbiten har blivit lite större nu och den växer lite för varje dag.
När tårtbiten är så stor ska den in i tårtan.
Och då jävlar.
Ja, så kan man hoppas, men det vet man aldrig.
Man tror alltid att man har så geniala idéer så man ska aldrig sitta och rida på höga äldstar.
När man har hållit på så länge som jag har gjort så är det så att jag satsar aldrig mer än att jag kan förora på något av de här bolagen.
Jag har alltid en kroppkudde rent privat så jag känner att jag inte vill leva med stressen över att någonting måste gå superbra.
Går det superbra blir jag så rik så att det blir snuskigt.
Går det dåligt påverkar det inte min vardag.
Det gör det inte om det går bra heller.
Det är viktigt att alla kompisar...
Det är bara vänner och vänners vänner som är här.
Det är alltså inget professionellt kapital i huvud taget.
Vi har byggt upp det bara med nätverk.
För folk som förstår digital media och digitala projekt.
Man måste förstå vad man satsar på.
Och se potentialen i ett skalbart internationellt bolag.
Det är där hälsdagen finns idag på pengarna.
Om man hittar en bra digital plattform som funkar i hela världen.
Då är det, du vet, vi bor ju som ett litet land.
Vi bor i en liten avkrok med tio miljoner människor.
Det är liksom ingenting.
Vi är en femtidel av en normal, en stor kinesisk stad.
Så när man ser hur stor världen är, man förstår det så är det skalbara projekt det enda roliga att jobba med.
Eftersom de har så extrem potential.
Jag kan bara säga som en avstickare här i podden, att nu hoppar vi egentligen över hela ditt privata liv.
Du pratade lite kort om att du hade en tuff period, att din fru gick bort, men du har ett avsnitt när du är med i en podd som heter Brottabröder där du pratar om ditt privata liv.
Där belyser du verkligen det.
Den delen så vill man lyssna på det, så kan man gå dit och lyssna på det avsnittet.
För där får man verkligen följa med på din resa.
Det tycker jag man kan rekommendera om.
Just den podcasten driva Martin Lidberg och hans brodor.
Martin och jag är också goda vänner.
Det var lite lättare att prata om det där inför en god vän.
Vi tränar ihop också var 14 idag ungefär.
Vi försöker köra varje vecka, men det är ofta var 14.
Han är med i en massa konstiga program på tv, bakning och grejer.
Vi är väldigt goda vänner, han är min absolut närmsta vän och han är fantastisk.
Jag måste säga att den podd-
casten har blivit väldigt bra.
Inte för att jag har varit med, men därför att de har bra gäster.
De ställer tuffa frågorna med kärlek och det är svårt.
Men de gör verkligen det.
Det var både lite ledsamt avsnitt men också rätt fint, men också är det jävligt roligt.
Vi ska inte fastna i det, men det är jävligt rolig historia när du trillar ner på en trappa.
Det är inte roligt för dig, men själva storyn i sig är rätt underhållande eller rätt fascinerande och allt som kommer där till.
Jag kan ju ta ett exempel på det här att beröka sig ljuset i tunneln.
När jag ramlade och drog av på patellascenen och fick operera mig och gå med den här orthoser under lång tid.
Så sa jag som folk förstår att det är en rolig story.
Ja det är ingen rolig story, det var fruktansvärd.
Men samtidigt kände jag att min första fråga var om jag kunde vara med då när det stod av dem.
Jag cyklar i mountainbike också så jag ville vara med i cykelvasan.
Jag tog av vårt hosna i januari, februari och sen var jag med i cykelvasan i augusti.
Det går om man vill för det tog en stund innan jag kunde böja knäleden så mycket så att man inte trampa runt tramporna.
Men jag trampade först bara med tån och sadeln på högsta och sen lägre och lägre och lägre.
Nu cyklar jag, jag har inte cyklat idag faktiskt.
Jag tycker att power biking som jag kallar det för det är en fantastisk cardioverksamhet därför att jag cyklar väldigt kort och väldigt hårt.
Därför att man behöver inte sitta och mata mil efter mil där man har tid med.
Utan jag kör mina runder som är mellan 25-35-40 minuter.
Men jag har maxpuls när jag kommer i mål.
Och det gör att man håller sig superform.
Så jag hade som mål att jag har en liten sladdis som heter Lowe, min son.
Han är 17 år nu och jag är 67.
Så vi ska faktiskt på, när blir det då?
Det blir nu bara en och en halv vecka så ska vi ta bilder tillsammans.
Far och son, 50 år emellan, ta fysikbilder.
Bara för att visa att man som äldre idag kan faktiskt vara en väldigt vital människa.
Och nu fick jag idag på mejlen, jag har sökt ut det hemvärnet, jag tycker att det händer något som jag vill sitta hemma som en gammal gubbe och titta på när de krigar utan de vill hjälpa till.
Jag tycker att de har avslagit mina ansökan för att det är för gammalt.
Då kände jag såhär, men herregud vilket gammaldags sätt, de tittar på den kronologiska ordningen och de tittar inte på den biologiska.
Så egentligen hade det varit mönstring för att bli hemvärnade, så hade många inte klarat det.
Men jag hade gått igenom det, därför jag klarar fyrstesterna, det vet jag.
Vad de än gör för tester.
Så egentligen ska man bedöma människas duglighet efter vad man kan prestera, inte efter vad det står i passet.
Jag skrev till myndigheterna nu ett långt mejl om att jag tycker att det var väldigt dåligt och att jag ansåg att man bedömer lämpligheten på fel grundkriterier.
Det var en fruktansvärt korkad bedömning.
Dessutom har man ju aldrig erfarenhet och man har ju kanske varit med.
Skriv till dem, googla på mig för fan.
Nej men alltså de har ju bara en mall år efter.
Man kan ju bara vara med i hemvandet när man är 70 år efter de regler som finns nu.
Men jag menar man ska kunna vara med i hemvandet så länge man är fysiskt duglig tycker jag.
Alltså inte det som är grunden här i livet.
Det finns ju någon som är 50 år som är vrak, eller 40 år som är vrak.
Men det kan springa en miler som inte kan göra en enda kinnapp eller inte kan lyfta en tung väskor från marken.
Nej det där behöver moderniseras.
Det är en lucka på marknaden.
Kan vi göra affärer på det.
Det är egna tester.
Hemvärns tester.
Jag tänkte säga att du ska träffa din son här också, men du har sagt att du jobbar med visioner, inte med mål och det tycker jag är lite intressant.
Kan du beskriva lite vad du har för visioner nu?
Absolut.
Nu har jag sålt alla mina bolag.
Jag har gjort i hela mitt liv det jag verkligen har tyckt är roligt.
Jag har aldrig gått till jobbet, jag har gått till min hobby.
Det har varit en vision att kunna jobba med sin hobby.
Det är otroligt roligt.
Därför att man är alltid ledig och man jobbar alltid.
Det är både för och nackdelar med det.
Det är top of mind hela tiden.
Samtidigt så är det inte jobbigt top of mind.
Och min vision idag, man kan göra vad man kallar för en dream board.
Det vill säga hur skulle jag vilja att mitt liv ser ut ifrån och med nu.
Den största lyxen för mig, därför att om man inte har ett inre lugn, då blir man inte lycklig om någonting.
Så jag har ett inre lugn idag.
Jag har gjort mina misstag, både när det gäller ena och andra.
Jag har gjort mina bolagsatsningar, det har gått bra ibland, det har gått dåligt ibland.
Jag har haft vänner som har kommit och gått, jag har haft kvinnor som har kommit och gått, jag har haft liksom...
Men i grund och botten så är det så att min dream board idag är att göra sådant fortfarande samma sak.
Jag gör sådant jag tycker är kul, men med mindre stress.
Och det är oerhört lyckligt.
Jag försöker vara lycklig varje dag och tänka på hur bra vi har det.
För första bor vi i en del av världen där vi kan tycka att vi har problem.
Men problemen är så oerhört små mot vad stora delar av världen har idag.
Vi ska vara väldigt lyckliga varje dag för att vi kan ta en varm dusch, som jag nämnde tidigare, för att vi kan äta och smätta.
Vi kan förhoppningsvis umgås med vänner, vi kan gå på restaurang, vi kan dricka vattnet direkt ur kranen, vi kan bada i vattnet.
Vi lever i ett lyxliv, även om vi inte har hög inkomst, så är det ett lyxliv i botten.
Det tänker man sällan på.
Så min vision är att njuta så mycket som möjligt utan det, ta hand om resten av livet och göra sånt jag tycker är kul.
Jag kommer nog aldrig att sluta jobba tror jag, för det tycker jag är en essentiell del av livet, att använda sin hjärna, kreativitet, skapa nya saker, kanske hjälpa andra människor.
Och idag, jag har en fosterhemsbaserad dotter också.
Hon skickar mig precis ett sms.
Jag ska ta det som exempel på vad jag verkligen tycker är fint.
Hon skriver så här till mig.
Nu ska jag ut och lämna henne lite, jag vill inte säga mycket mer än så.
Hon skriver så här.
Ove, jag har hittat en supergullig del av organisationen som heter äldre kontakt.
Det hela går ut på att en grupp om åtta pensionärer samlas som volontärer på en fika.
Tvärför bara sitter där och pratar helt enkelt.
De träffas en gång i månaden på söndagar.
Man kan bli volontär där gratis.
Då kommer fikan att ske hemma hos oss med alla dessa pensionärer.
Jag funderar på om jag ska bli volontär.
Ärligt talat så älskar jag ungdomar med de äldre.
De påminner om min mormor, hennes mormor då.
De ger mig ett slags lugn i skälen.
Sen så beror jag faktiskt inte så mycket om våra äldres brev.
Men faktiskt mycket om att vara äldre i samhället inte ska vara ensamma.
Ensamheten, isolering, ibland äldre är faktiskt ett riktigt problem.
De har ju byggt upp detta land och kämpat för de rättigheterna jag har idag.
Men i alla fall så måste jag självklart fråga dig först, om du tycker det är okej om de är hemma hos oss.
Får jag bli volontär och fika över dina för dem en gång i månaden hemma hos oss i stan?
Fan vad grym månen är, fan vad härligt, vad roligt.
På 19 år, och då känner jag såhär, och då klart vad svar jag då, underbart mål, självklart.
Det här är väl underbart för att ensamhet är ju någonting som är fruktansvärt.
Stockholm är ju en stad där det finns något enormt utbud men också en enorm ensamhet.
Och då helst när du har ett ensamhushåll då.
Och de äldre är ju såhär att även om du har några goda vänner så dör ju de.
Men sitter de där på åldern, 80-90 år gamla, man har inte en vän kvar.
Så jag tycker det var så himla fint.
Så jag ska fråga den nu, hur gammal ska man vara för att vara med?
Sådana saker är ju viktigt att kanske stötta och ta tag i och försöka vara lite mer givmild mot sin omgivning och försöka stötta de som behöver.
Och då är du ändå den onda broschan.
Ja det vet jag.
Tänk vad snälla han måste vara.
Jag hjälper en del entreprenörer också med att komma igång och försöka ge dem lite goda råd.
Jag ger aldrig rådet att det är bara att köra, utan jag säger att man ska väldigt väl...
Att säga att det är bara att köra är väldigt oansvarigt.
Det är inte bara att köra.
Man måste ha en grund i sin idé, man måste ha en intäktsmodell, man måste ha en realistisk plan, man måste vara beredd att jobba hårt, man måste vara duktig på det man gör, och man ska försöka gräva där man står.
Och du menar att man ska gräva i sitt inre på de områden man brinner för.
Då lyckas vandelängden om man jobbar hårt.
Ja, det var bra.
För min sista fråga var, vilka råd hade du gett in, intreprenör?
Men jag känner att du sammanfattar dem ganska fint där.
Jag kände att den frågan var på gång.
Ove, det har varit fantastiskt kul att ha med dig i vården.
Oerhört mycket kunskap som bara flödar ut.
Jag skulle kunna sitta här i fyra timmar till, men jag vet att du ska träffa din son.
Jag hör mina barn skrika.
Exakt, vi sa att vi skulle sitta en timme, men vi har suttit exakt en timme.
Det är perfekt.
Så jag tror inte folk orkar lyssna längre på mig ändå.
Jag finns alltid tillgänglig om det är någon som är entreprenör i branschen, så kan man alltid mejla till mig eller kontakta mig.
För jag tycker det är kul att hjälpa till och jag är den typen av människa som jag har aldrig betalt.
Utan jag gör istället så att om det är ett uppdrag jag får, om någon vill hjälp så gör jag alltid så att jag tar hellre en liten procent i bolaget för att hjälpa till gratis.
Så är det så att det går bra, då är det en bra affär för dem och en bra affär för mig.
Oerhört hipsvängen, då får jag ingenting.
Jag tycker det är ganska schysst att göra så, det blir mindre tröskel.
Och så gör jag idag med ett antal bolag och det är faktiskt ganska roligt, speciellt när några går ganska bra.
Och då blir det gärna roligare att jobba.
Så jag finns där, speciellt inom hälsoindustrin, då tycker jag det är kul såklart, men även inom tech-projekt.
Det gör jag lite också, det tycker jag är skoj.
Mest för att det ska vara en meningsfull vardag och man ska göra saker man är hyfsat kompetent med.
Perfekt, stort tack Ove.
Tack för att du skulle vara med.
Vi lever ett lyxliv, även om vi inte har hög inkomst, så är det ett lyxliv i botten.